[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous vous vous demandez
peut-être quel est le lien entre la
perspective de rejoindre et de relier
une autre planète et indiana jones et
les aventuriers de l'arche erreur 404
l'été de mes 20 ans je m'en souviens
très bien c'était la mission la sonde
pathfinder sur mars
si un chercheur de chemin trouveur de
chemin ça comme un petit peu à voir cet
amusant avec ce que je vais vous
raconter
c'était l'été de mes 20 ans et je tombe
donc sur un article sur les premières
missions habitées vers mars
à l'horizon 2020 l'époque puisque depuis
la fin des années 50 cet horizon de 30
ans glisse pour de très très bonnes
raisons mais toujours il ya quelques
années du moins ils étaient encore
placées à 30 ans la vertige de mes 20
ans je je prends conscience qu'une
fenêtre technologique est en train de
s'ouvrir et que pour la première fois
depuis l'histoire de l'humanité qu'il ya
deux cent mille ans quand même pour sa
15 nous sommes en mesure d'atteindre une
autre planète dans notre génération
ça me fait réfléchir à beaucoup de
choses
héééé on pourrait se poser la question
oui bon mais quelle est l'urgence à
l'échelle cosmologique d'atteindre notre
une autre planète
alors certains inquiet ou catastrophisme
éclairé comme stephen hawking ou lots de
masques peuvent vous dire ok cette
fenêtre technologique est en train de
s'ouvrir main peut se refermer beaucoup
plus tôt qu'on ne le pense à l'ère de
l'anthropocène et puis de l'impact qu'on
a sur eux sur notre environnement et
d'autres comme saint-exupéry et sa
morale de l'action qui se dit chacun
seul est responsable pour tous les
générations suivantes auront bien à ces
deux défis à relever
donc ce qu'on peut ce sûr qu'on peut
travailler dès maintenant il faut le
faire alors pourquoi aller sur mars
pourquoi l'exploration habitée
complémentaire avec l'exploration
robotique de mars est elle cruciale est
définie comme crucial depuis le début de
l'astronautique il ya la technologie
dont on vient de parler apprendre à
vivre dans l'espace et a fortiori sur
une autre planète
c'est résoudre tout un tas de
problématiques très terrestre vous savez
que l'exploration spatiale est un des
meilleurs investissements de l'humanité
c'est un des meilleurs vecteurs de
coopération certes mais on a des tas de
retomber une pluie de retomber
omniprésente dans notre quotidien
jusqu'à ce smartphone puisqu'on parle de
deux connexions aujourd'hui et en
médecine on pourrait citer une liste
très longue de retombées de ce spin off
qui sont des spin-off attendu 1 quand il
faut s'agit de de vivre plus que de
survivre sur une autre planète et bien
il faut résoudre et optimiser la gestion
des ressources le recyclage évidemment
pour n'en citer que quelques-uns donc
des spin-off attendu puis ce qui est
intéressant aussi c'est tous et toutes
ses retombées inattendues la sérendipité
ç'a toujours été très intéressant est à
l'origine de bon dans notre dans notre
histoire de bons évolutif parce que
quand on trouve quelque chose qu'on ne
cherchait pas parce qu'on est ouvert à
ce qu'on observe
il y a aussi une valeur ajoutée un
supplément d'âme
donc on peut on peut penser à la
technologie il ya aussi la science il ya
quand même une question essentielle de
notre histoire qui est celle de la vie
dans l'univers qui trouve au moins des
réponses partielles dans la prochaine
planète accessible à notre génération
vous savez proxima bc4 deux années
lumières sert 80 mille ans de propulsion
classique
pour atteindre ces 4000 exoplanètes
qu'on découvre presque tous les jours
depuis la fin des années 90 donc la
prochaine accéder planète accessible
c'est clairement mars
en plus on a tous les ingrédients pour
que la vie émergent sur mars la vie
telle qu'on la connaît en tout cas
dépendant de la chimie du carbone
dépendant de l'eau liquide en zone
habitable de son étoile d'énergie donc
si on ne retrouve de la vie passée ou
présente sur mars aujourd'hui c'est
évidemment une découverte fantastique ça
veut dire que l'univers est bio friendly
et si on songe aux exoplanètes c'est
vertigineux
et puis si on trouve pas de vie passée
ou présente c'est intéressant aussi
soissons la science et poser des
questions et affiner son modèle au fur
et à mesure des réponses trouvées et
c'est très intéressant scientifiquement
en soit là et puis la planétologie
comparée aussi comprendre quelle a été
l'évolution sur mars pour comprendre un
petit peu mieux la terre
la planète mars qui est quand même un
livre ouvert sur l'histoire du début du
système solaire qui s'est effacé sur
terre puisque mars on pense était plus
plus accueillante que la terre quand la
vie a émergé il ya 4 milliards d'années
sur terre mais cette époque là c'était
face et sur la terre à peu de choses
près du fait de la tectonique du fait de
l'activité de notre planète et tout
s'est arrêté sur mars
donc c'est un livre ouvert sur cette
époque là qui évidemment
scientifiquement passionnant puis à des
questions pour plus profond des
motivations bien plus profondes qui sont
d'ordre philosophique y sommes nous
allons nous des questions existentielles
évidemment la nature de l'homme est
interrogé évidemment et toutes ces
grandes questions sont convoqués quand
on réfléchit aux missions habitées vers
mars
pourquoi on sort du berceau comment
pourquoi cette nature humaine nous
pousse à explorer 1
la terre étant à protéger et en notre
berceau mais de tout temps les humains
ou parmi eux lui d indiana jones et des
explorateurs qui sont sortis d'une autre
confortables ont pris des risques
quelquefois considérable pour pour
explorer donc ça interroge soucier puis
ça nous place aussi dans une autre
perspective parce qu'il s'agit pas
d'injecter quelques hommes et femmes
dans l'espace
il s'agit de placer toute l'humanité
dans une perspective différente est
décentré j'espère qu'il ya quelques des
centraliens dans dans l'assemblée parce
que quand on se décentre on change de
perspective on a un élargissement du
champ de conscience et on mesure
l'importance de la protection planétaire
c'est ce que décrivent tous les
astronautes quand ils reviennent ils
connaissaient les photos d'apollo 8 et
du lever de terre mais quand ils le
voient de leurs yeux il ya un cognitif
shift overview effect c'est cet
élargissement du champ de conscience qui
impose et qui nous fait un carnet et
prouver réellement l'importance de la
protection de notre planète donc
s'intéresser à mars et s'intéresser à la
terre c'est surtout pas se dire allez on
va recommencer tout ce qu'on a mal fait
sur terre avec une planète plan b c'est
tout l'un versent jusqu'à aujourd'hui
oui mais comment atteindre la planète
mars on a parlé de l'horizon 30 ans et
on pouvait pas imaginer jusqu'à une
époque très récente que d'autres entités
des agences spatiales gouvernementale en
coopération internationale puisse mener
un projet aussi ambitieux et complexe
qu'une mission habitée vers mars qui
soulève des défis dans tous les sens et
pourtant on voit et c'est d'actualité
puisque space x pour ne citer qu'eux
space x vient d'ouvrir une nouvelle ère
qui est celle du voyage spatial
commercial
il ya quelques jours avec sa mission des
mots 1 et quand vous signez quand vous
êtes ingénieur et voulait travailler
pour pour space x
clairement vous signez vous contribuez
vous voulez contribuer à faire de
l'espèce humaine une espèce multi
planétaire l'espèce humaine et c'est pas
le champion physiologiques de
l'adaptation à l'espace ça on peut le
laisser pour ce qui est des
multicellulaires ao tardigrade qui
supporte le vide des radiations
incroyable dépression folle par contre
notre incroyable immaturité en tant
qu'espèce à l'âge adulte
cette persistance de caractère juvénile
qu'on appelle la néoténie c'est une
chance formidable puisque c'est ce qui
nous permet de développer une culture de
la fiction qui nous permet d'être juché
sur les épaules des géants et de
transmettre l'information
et puis évidemment de l'art et de la
science et de la technologie parce que
même sur terre à certains coins reculés
de la planète peut être pas forcément
très reculées quelquefois simplement en
plein hiver à paris vous ne survivrez
pas à 100 sans avoir une technologie à
commencer par par vêtements et un
habitat mais voici la vision d'elon musk
c'est son grand port ps c'est un
ingénieur entrepreneur et sa vision de
l'espèce humaine multi planétaire centré
autour de l'ingéniosité on est on est
dans un lieu où on rencontre des esprits
ingénieux ressemble à ça avec une
navette interplanétaire énorme
le pal starship maintenant et qui est
capable de transporter une centaine de
personnes de la terre à mars puis de
mars à la terre voilà ça c'était
inenvisageable en 2002 quand on voit à
quoi ressemblait space x ted saintais de
space x aujourd'hui à cette époque-là
2002 voilà à quoi ressemble et space x
est donc tout le monde le prenait pour
un fou tout le monde souriait il
manquait pas complètement de crédibilité
puisqu'il avait quelques réussites et
des échecs puisque c'est une bonne
occasion d'apprendre les échecs
entreprenariale c'est un ingénieur
entrepreneur et sa mission voilà comment
il commence en 2008 il est sauvé par la
nasa d'ailleurs ça s'est joué à un fil
et ce qui est intéressant dans la
dans la proche d'elon musk c'est la
combinaison de deux choses la première
c'est une vision naïve hors cadre qui
manque cruellement en fait aux experts
on est tous des experts dans un domaine
après un certain une certaine expérience
pratique mais on se formatent on n'est
pas forcément conscients de ça son
formatage culturelle et son formatage
professionnels dont on ne voit plus
certaines solutions hors cadre qu'on
avait déjà traité mais avec d'autres
outils et qu'on a rejeté quand on est
naïf quand on est novice et l'intérêt du
transdisciplinaires on voit des
solutions auxquelles les autres
n'avaient pas pensé par exemple la
réutilisabilité totale du lanceur il
s'est dit c'est quand même dommage quand
on fait un bordeaux lyon de jeter
l'avion à chaque fois donc
réutilisabilité de l'ensemble du lanceur
et les experts souriez on a déjà traité
ça pour la navette spatiale c'était
l'objectif est de ce point de vue là ça
a été un échec partiel
cette navette spatiale qu'on arrête en
2011 et en fait si si si c'est ça qu'il
faut qu'on fasse c'est d'ailleurs
maintenant la proche aussi blue origin
avec jeff bezos ce cela dit si on est
uni qu'on aille y fait qu'on se donne
pas les moyens et qu'on relève pas le
niveau
s'entourant très très bien en étant bon
moment on n'y arrive pas donc ensuite et
bévilard
il a potassé 600 bouquin de roquettes
sérieuse et il est arrivé au niveau d'un
ingénieur aérospatial et puis surtout il
s'est fait très bien entouré et donc il
a réussi non seulement la
réutilisabilité total et puis là il
ajouté beaucoup d'astuces dans son
approche polyvalent d'ailleurs pour
l'ensemble du système solaire pour
justement augmenter les cadences et abc
vraiment le coût de l'accès à l'espace
dans cet effort de démocratisation de
l'espace
aujourd'hui ceux qui peuvent aller sur
mars vu le prix d'entrée évidemment ce
cercle à neuneu chevauchent absolument
pas ce qu'ils ont envie ou qui veulent
aller sur mars et se dit si on veut
vraiment débuter une civilisation multi
planétaire et bien il faut que les deux
cercles se chevauchent
donc il faut faire des économies
d'échelle décadence et donc c'était le
but c'est la réussite
de space x et c'est d'autant plus la
réussite on sait pourquoi des entités
privées qui développe à savoir faire
aujourd'hui c'est l'émergence du
servette du spatial privé qui est
clairement la traction la force de
traction dans le spatial c'est plus la
guerre froide des années 60 et du
programme apollo
c'est l'émergence du spatial privé c'est
la force de traction et qui maintenant
se hisse au niveau de superpuissance
grâce à cette courbe d'alluré
exponentielle c'est à dire que c'est ce
qui autorise finalement l'évolution
exponentielle des technologies quand
nous on pense linéaire c'est vraiment ce
qui autorise finalement de penser
moonshot les fameux moonshot r je
m'attaque un problème transformant
massif j'envisage une solution radicale
qui peut faire sourire
d'accord ou ou pire parce qu'en fait les
bonnes idées qui sont des bonnes idées
tout le monde les a celle qui ouvre des
océans bleus c'est les mauvaises idées
qui sont des bonnes idées
après il ya des mauvaises idées qui sont
vraiment de mauvaise idée et puis vous
utiliser les technologies nos très
innovante est exponentielle et l'a
finalement du visionnaire c'est de
s'entourer et d'être là au bon moment
c'est une question de timing si vous
avez une idée excellente beaucoup trop
tôt sur la courbe ça ne se transformera
pas si vous êtes en retard et c'est le
problème des grosses organisations qui
ont d'inertie et c'est pour ça que
l'horizon 30 ans qui pour des raisons
essentiellement politiques d'ailleurs
glisse budgétaires et politiques n'ont
pas la cinétique que space x a
aujourd'hui dans la perspective d'une
mission habitée vers mars
bon ça crée aussi des dérives puisque
cette idée là exponentielle et
uniquement exponentielle qui fait penser
ensuite aura la singularité
l'intelligence artificielle elle est en
fait philosophiquement matérialiste
c'est à dire que on pense quand on est
dans cette pensée là que de toute
complexité émerge une nouvelle propriété
tout ce qu'on observe par exemple le
cerveau la conscience c'est le produit
d'un cerveau complexe c'est matérialiste
au sens philosophique c'est oublier
quelques fois que les cours peuvent
ressembler beaucoup plus à des sigmoïde
ça on en est familier quand on est
médecin ya une saturation c'est par
exemple le cerveau est une superbe
machine pour aller piocher l'information
en dehors de l'espace temps on peut
imaginer qu'on n'arrivera pas
l'intelligence artificielle forte et que
ça sature ah mais c'est un autre sujet
en fait le futur est imprévisible à un
vraisemblable toujours faux pas planifié
le futur la prospective c'est pas du
présent continuer linéaire entre a et b
ça c'est toujours faux les révolutions
paradigmatique tout tout tout le la
courbe en fait des grandes révolutions
sont toujours comme ça en vagues en
rupture est en marche d'escalier y
compris notre commission ça c'est là les
travaux qui gagnent sur la cognition
évolutive l'évolution de la commission
qui en fait sur un cerveau qui se
complexifie certes mais commence deux
tiers des adultes sont dans une
condition socialiser dire qu'on cherche
une direction à se conformer à la norme
à la pensée de notre groupe social ou de
notre culture
sans forcément avoir du recul et s'en
apercevoir et puis le la cognition auto
réalisant qu'un tiers d'entre nous
atteignent finalement c'est cette
processus d'individuation jeu j'apprends
à piloter sur mon propre chemin
finalement même s'il s'écarte un peu de
la pensée classique et jeu
je j'ai du recul justement sur mon
formatage ce processus d'individuation
permet de mieux me connaître et de
savoir quelle est ma propre vision du
monde même si elle est un petit peu
différenciée est très très peu arrivent
à cette commission auto transformante
que des criques et gan qui est tellement
individus et qu'on peut se débarrasser
de lego et se mettre véritablement au
service de la vision du monde qui fait
sens vision du monde qui peut être
d'ailleurs très diverses et
contradictoires pour naviguer fluidement
entre différentes visions du monde
quelquefois même qui paraissent opposée
et bien c'est une des caractéristiques
de cette commission là d'accord et je
pilote pour apprendre et non plus
simplement pour piloter le vaisseau sont
des méta leader d'un gandhi mandela par
exemple est en fête et paradoxe sur les
missions habitées vers mars ils sont
partout alors pour n'en citer que deux
par exemple on veut des indiana jones
qui avait exploré
oui peut-être mais ils seront très très
contraint ils auront un sacré manque de
liberté puisqu'ils seront emprisonnés
dans un habitat dont ils dépendront
totalement il dépend totalement du
support vie donc évidemment c'est un peu
paradoxal pour des explorateurs et puis
front de l'extraordinaire au quotidien
dans un quotidien ordinaire extrêmement
ennuyeux et monotone donc paradoxe et
pour dépasser les paradoxes décentration
des centrales c'est à dire qu'en fait il
faut intégrer des choses qui
apparaissent opposé à première vue dans
quelque chose de plus large et qui
résout le paradoxe donc c'est ce qui m'a
toujours finalement intéressé alors
voilà en parlant de dévolution de la
commission est de 80 à indiana jones que
je vous ai passé très brièvement tout à
l'heure voilà quatre ans j'étais déjà
passionné par le voyage spatial
or c'est pas raisonnable du tout 571
personnes ont volé dans l'espace à ce
jour c'est en train de changer
quand même il n'y a pas d'école centrale
pour pour devenir astronaute
alors comment on fait et puis je vous ai
dit les plans et des cases à cocher ça
marche pas le futur est toujours assez
difficile à prévoir
m'enfin n'empêche que à l'âge adulte ils
continuent à m'envoyer des bonnes ondes
à me faire vibrer dès qu'on parle et du
spatial donc ça voulait bien dire
quelque chose à me donner à penser
quelque chose cet enfant intérieur
finalement et le meilleur capitaine de
notre vaisseau cette part de nous-mêmes
pluripotentes ouverte sur le monde
curieuse elle nous dit des choses il
faut pas le faire taire à l'âge de
raison totalement il fera peut-être
n'importe quoi par contre dans le
vaisseau s'il n'a pas un super copilote
qui est le sage vous voyez à kegan sait
s'il ya bien quelque chose qui peut
grandir à l'âge adulte c'est bien la
sagesse et il faut faire dialoguer
probablement cet autre part de
nous-mêmes futur qu'il faut laisser
s'épanouir et grandir qui est la sagesse
et qui permet de dépasser les paradoxes
et qui la meilleure chance de s'adapter
à un monde complexe un monde complexe et
les paradoxale pour s'y adapter ya rien
de mieux que la cognition auto
transformante et dialoguer avec cet
enfant intérieur et tous les deux ils
vont mener la barque de façon assez
pertinente
ce qui m'amène en rapport avec le thème
de ce soir et de la journée à vous
parler de la reliance la théorie de la
reliance général qui a été repris par
edgar morin pour dans sa pensée complexe
et développer un outil formidable de
compréhension du monde dans lequel nous
vivons
parce que nous comprenons non seulement
nous sommes tous interconnectés et
interdépendants je vous dis pas
l'équipage sur mars combien il dépendra
de ses coéquipiers pour survivre donc
mais mais un astronaute dans les ss il
dépend de toute l'équipe tient au sol et
qui travaille depuis des années sur la
mission donc en fait évidemment un
astronaute c'est juste un épiphénomène
du vaisseau terre spatiale qui voyagent
dans le système solaire et donc c'est à
la fois ça mais c'est aussi créer du
lien activement et relié en fait dans un
monde complexe les concepts le monde des
idées et le monde qui se cristallise et
qui s'actualise chacun d'entre nous et
pour faire émerger du sens et j'aimerais
et comment c'est qu'on est sur le bon
chemin
j'aimerais vous introduire un autre
concept qui est celui de l'ikigami qu'on
emprunte aux japonais cette fois parce
qu'il y aura des détours c'est pas tout
droit comme le pont dit diana jones qui
est franchie c'est vraiment des détours
désynchronisation des échecs faut tomber
ceux relevés çà c'est ça qui est
intéressant
on sait qu'on est donc sur le bon chemin
quand on trouve finançons nikki gaye qui
traduit par la raison d'être mais c'est
en fait cette cohérence est reliant
centre qu'est ce donc moi je prends du
plaisir
pourquoi je vibre pour le spatial dans
quoi je pense que je suis compétent dans
quoi je peux m'employer
et comment à mon échelle ça c'est une
dimension importante je peux contribuer
à changer un petit peu le monde voilà
est au centre de tout ça vous avez
liquide aie aie ça vous permet entre
votre inside votre enfant intérieur et
votre le sage qu'il faut laisser un peu
grandir ça vous permet à chaque fois de
vous ajustez de savoir où tu surfes et
d'ailleurs au sens de joël de rosnay
dans un monde complexe et un
déterministe c'est une question de
timing d'alignement et de succession
d'équilibrés déséquilibres comme quand
on marche
et pour terminer pour conclure
finalement j'aimerais peut-être pourquoi
pas méditer sur l'idée que si on veut
véritablement vivre dans un futur qui
est porteur de sens pour nous plutôt que
suivre des chemins qui sont
prédéterminés peut-être bien que la
meilleure chance d'anticiper de vivant
ce monde-là ses deux co créé ce futur de
co-créer le chemin parce que s'il est
porteur de sens
nous sommes le chemin je vous remercie
beaucoup
[Applaudissements]